>> Mark: THE INTOLERANT LEFT
HAS ENGAGED IN AN AGGRESSIVE
CAMPAIGN TO SILENCE AND
INTIMIDATE SPEAKERS THEY
DISAGREE WITH.
CONSIDER THE SCENE AT THE CITY
UNIVERSITY OF NEW YORK LAW
SCHOOL WHERE ANGRY LEFT-WING
STUDENTS SHOUTED DOWN A FREE
SPEECH ADVOCATE.
>> THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
HAVING ME.
>> WE ARE NOT HAVING YOU.
>> THE ANSWER IS TO CHANGE THE
LAW.
>> WHAT YOU ARE A LAW SCHOOL.
>> Mark: WHEN THEY'RE NOT
SILENCING CONSERVATIVES, THEY'RE
THREATENING TO ATTACK THEM.
MOVIE STAR ROBERT DE NIRO CALLS
TRUMP "THE LOWLIFE IN CHIEF" AND
IN THE PAST, HE SAID THIS.
SPEAK OUT THIS IS THE PRESIDENT.
THE GUY IS A [BLEEP] FULL.
OF COURSE I WANT TO PUNCH HIM IN
THE FACE.
>> Mark: BRING IT ON, THEN
THERE IS LIKELY THE THE LEFT
EXPRESSED ONLINE AT THE NEWS OF
BARBARA BUSH DEATH.
R.I.P. BARBARA BUSH, THE ONLY
WOMAN WHO IS 92 FOR 30 YEARS.
BARBARA BUSH WAS A GENEROUS AND
SMART AMAZING RACIST TO ALONG
WITH HER HUSBAND RAISED A WAR
CRIMINAL.
F OUT OF HERE WITH YOUR NICE
WORDS.
JOSH BLACKMAN IS THE PROFESSOR
YOU JUST SAW HERE HE WAS SHOUTED
DOWN AT THE LAW SCHOOL AND HE
JOINS US TONIGHT.
JOSH, YOU WERE GIVING A SPEECH
ON FREE SPEECH AND THE POSITION
OF YOUR OPPONENT IS THAT FREE
SPEECH NOW IS JUST ANOTHER
EXAMPLE OF WHITE SUPREMACY,
WHITE PRIVILEGE, WHITE
NATIONALISM AND ALL THE REST OF
IT.
>> EXACTLY.
I TRIED TO COME ON CAMPUS TO
TALK ABOUT FREE SPEECH AND I WAS
SHOUTED DOWN HERE THEY YELLED AT
ME, THEY SCREAMED AT ME, THEY